alors benjamin castadi qu'à passer des
vacances sans rigoler à nous montrer son
corps à nous montrer sa meuf
c'est un truc que je dirai pas quand
même alors passer des photos regarder
castaldi regardeur kassar a posté on
peut la montre est magnifique quelle
beauté mais que la nasa là on sait qui
se mariera pas attendre et bah écoute et
j'adore parce que j'ai les mêmes plantes
à la maison qu'est ce qu'elle est belle
votre dos alors c'est oui elle est belle
sa femme est bien vrai oui bien dessinés
psy franchement et vous être devenu bon
je vous regarde une belle poitrine alors
vous avez croisé de [ __ ] il me suit et
il est un petit peu c'est peu mais c'est
parce que j'ai pas enlever les poils à
son et conseils de mathieu suivait pas
les conseils de matinée les confères
alors les vacances de benhaim qu'est-ce
qu'il serra sera dominique oui je
m'attendais regardez l'école à laquelle
elle est belle à la à la salade à l'état
belge en haut là là je fais un peu frisé
c'est pas mon prochain
vous savez qu'on a on à laterrière merci
et donc à quoi d'autre ah ouais en fait
tu vas t'y chambre non mais écoutez dans
mes champs réglé aux dires et là on
dirait la photo de la queue de la
correspondante anglais ce que tu vas
recevoir xinhua
[Applaudissements]
quant à l'école la récolte de fonds
ouais alors la semaine prochaine il ya
donc birgitta qui vient de cambridge
tu verras donc regarde ces photos non
mais attendez il sourit c'est quoi ces
vacances s'est posée c'est ringard
j'ai raconté le gérant les endroits
sympas et ne racontez pas me racontait
les nouvelles dans l'équipe
delphine wespiser on va voir tes
vacances voilà là c'est un autre délire
pas des copies non mais franchement
c'est important parce que normalement
toi tu me mesure combien un médecin 15
tu poses du combien ça me 40 40 ça va
parce que tu as pas d y est douce tu
vois ce que normalement je connais cette
année neuf normalement de cette taille
là sont des péniches quoi sans déconner
c'est un truc de ouf j'ai déjà remarqué
parce qu'en plus les pieds sur une photo
c'est un détail ma communauté qui me
suit et en gros kiff sur les pieds donc
je recevrai ouais vraiment et c'est trés
fait gaffe quand même devoir attaquer
quand on n'a pas de toit oui on va
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est votre chance
non mais non ils ne sont pas là on a
tout un débrief sur cette émission parce
qu'on ne sait pas qui c'est votre chat
tu sais pas on faisait les bois poêles
mais quand même ce qui en fait c'est mon
chéri je vous expliquais d'achat en fait
le truc c'était très marrant on dormait
et à 3 heures du matin j'entends des
bruits comme ça afin d'aider des bruits
donc je savais pas si je vais allumer la
lumière
quoi qu'il en soit j'ai allumé la
lumière des là je regarde et il y avait
un chat dans notre lit non tiaret est
pas de ce fruit il est rentré chiant
comme ça j'étais ballet de rire et en
fait c'est le chat du voisin qui est
rentré par notre fenêtre improbable à
dire que tu te réveilles tu un chat au
cul jean-michel merci d'être là c'est
votre nouveau look très chic
je vous avais décidé d'être chic
c'est une décision qui penche sur les
dix premiers jours a dû annoncer mais la
solution assez une résolution vous avez
décidé tchèque puisque vous avez trouvé
l'amour
exactement alors parfois beaucoup quand
même c'est que ça fait plusieurs fois
qu'il trouve l'amour a si souvent non
mais là c'est un vrai si c'est un vrai
bon alors c'est vrai vous étiez avec une
concubine fine rit aux éclats
oui oui ça s'est terminé pendant les
vacances les vacances font très mal aux
couples à je sais que ça ne vous
concerne pas daniel les batailles font
très mal généralement beaucoup je vous
le dis c'est enfin le salon sony des
mois dans sa cause et deux ans ça
consolide quand on est vieux benetton et
patins sadc litre et demi son droit
toutes les tentations on était fait beau
et vous l'avez connu où j'ai connu juste
avant les vacances à une soirée dont on
se doutait que ce n'était pas dans une
bibliothèque ou à un colloque à oui oui
vous l'avez dit quoi tu bois un verre je
sais plus
bah non c'est regarder plutôt ça a été
électrique ah oui il y avait des il y
avait des stroboscopes on accule 6 senti
qu'on était un peu fait l'appoint
d'autres d'accord alors est-ce contenant
alors je sais qu'elle est sur un stade
oui elle a montré bien sûr là vraiment
dans ses roadmaps c'est parti c'était
pas seront installés sur le siam et j'ai
été tagués et ça me fait très plaisir
bien sûr j'aimerais vraiment aller alors
elle est très jolie une fois de plus et
jean mi bravo à eux
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire et maroilles au duc on
reçoit des gens qui trouvent deux
manches comme en août de recevoir marois
j'ai mis plusieurs photos mais ça c'est
ma voisine
j'embrasse et inès habito ne viennent
que je suis pas sélectif guerre mon
chien ma copine m'a alors voilà 11 ans
qu'ils étaient non mais c'est pas
méchant nazi john a lâché je suis
rassuré et bien sûr nous a montré une
photo de magma vrai car mais on va
là-bas voisine il parle à tous et
pendant l'émission mais je peux vous
dire mon cher pour les vacances
quoique cfgt gamecube il mais j'ai pas
que passer les vacances assez horrible
mais sans doute moins permettez je vous
le dis pourquoi pas ce que je bois un
verre de monsieur que pendant les
vacances les deux mois on n'est pas
ensemble
et bah ma vie n'est pas plus beaucoup de
sens j'ai même un autre aveu à vous
faire c'est que début août j'ai failli
vous appeler et pourquoi je n'ai pas
fait ce qu'on avait pu voir fait
j'aimerais faire lui si j'entends vos
devoirs jeu peut-être même être à
chialer comme à gauche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est menteur de tellement beau merci
maman bons comédiens merci daniel moreau
nous enjoint ça y est quel bonheur
toujours célibataire bonjour la fleur au
fusil
toujours en vie elles ont envie de
trouver chaussure à son pied mais si
franchement c'est vrai et on retrouve le
jeu
[Musique]
mme avait paraît-il écrit un poème parie
que vous avez une histoire à nous
raconter un petit conte de fées de l'été
ah oui notre histoire
ouais bail entre vous oui un bail
ouais mais très court de droite c'est
parti pendant demain je n'entends pas me
permets pas d'immigrés il était une fois
la matinée il était une fois une jeune
fille brooke est une vieille fille qui
rêvait au prince charmant un jour de
février 2010 est le regard de prince
cyril et le coup de foudre fut immédiat
mais la famille de la jeune fille ne
voyaient pas cette histoire d'un très
bon oeil
il la mettait en garde pour son bien
attention cyril va entraîner dans drôle
d'endroit te faire faire des choses
bizarres
malgré les recommandations les amoureux
essayer de se voir en cachette alors
difficile de cacher ses sentiments sur
le plateau du premier tome show de
france et leurs yeux en disait long a
fini par de jim rogers de sa chère et
tendre à la jeune fille
et maintenir car se marier pour le
meilleur et pour le rire
[Applaudissements]
la mousse lancé chasse pour aller on
attend avec impatience
on attend avec impatience la nuit no
mercy date en tout cas vous a libéré de
france télévisions ils sont très sympas
mais ça n'était plus de votre âge
j'appelle maureen bottes isabel est
partie avec son mari en vacances vous
avez fait quoi laisser vous êtes vous
êtes hyper belle isabelle et cette
épaule à la ccpo et cette magnifique
vous de plus en plus un art je sais pas
ce que je peux faire pour vous ce que
lui vous fait une déclaration elle elle
vous fais une lettre robben arrivé sans
rire non mais nous faisons rien ma
chérie qu'est ce t'as fait penser va
construire garde un petit peu ce que tu
as fait avec lesquelles bon n'a pas
alors tout est beau vous mettez les
chaussures trop petites
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur la guimauve r non vous savez le
droit 37 donnez moi du 34 jeunes mais
vous commencez alors cet été on a eu
plus de chance de le voir sur teen
d'heures que à la télévision je
reconnais que j'étais petit coquin ah
ouais alors il paraît sans trahir un
secret on arrive vous avez eu 28
conquête sort à huy ensuite
ouais ok tu sais ce qu'on m'avait dit
abdou tu le dis comme ça partout colosse
tu te jettes ça comme ça c'était le
chiffre médiocre 28 contre rendez compte
on voit gratuite
j'avoue page et à nikon haut j'étais à
part cela arrêté j'étais j'ai bien
rigolé on a fait les places gay de
barcelona j'adorais ce que lui
normalement sans rigoler à des mecs qui
rentrent de vacances non écoute j'ai
fait toute la cour dira descendre écoute
après j'ai visité l'afrique du sud ne
s'est gêné non au chaud j'ai fait toutes
les plages que c'était très mignon il
découpa m'avait donné un petit surnom
cédéthèque était très chaud par l'accord
et des saignements vraie [ __ ]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
sur la place et la plainte devant la
face à l'autre notre merci vous avez dit
comme ça vous mettez pas de la glace
alors on danse pas de chocolat
attention là mais franchement et ben
écoutez c'est très affectueux qu'elle
dit est content d'être dur voilà alors
voilà voilà voilà
allez au moins heureusement merci d'être
là voilà a franchement j'hésitais soit
entre m nabila et vous j'ai fait le bon
choix
[Applaudissements]
le soir au bar l'escale
on va beaucoup rigolé salle et oui
madame s'est fait beaucoup de plages
comme mathieu oui vous connaissez pas
les arts et funds of funds à monza
weapons à jeter quoi hein juste en face
de rome ouais bah moi c'est comme ça en
face de rendre le sel a donc j'étais sur
une île magnifique et ça c'est votre
fille qu'elle est belle elle a eu quinze
ans et là vous étiez sur une plage une
plage déserte tout l'état bien moi je
vois pas observé louis la plage belles
vacances de ma vie sinon c'est vrai oui
eh bien écoutez on va savoir pourquoi
parce que je chante aux états unis pour
la première fois de ma vie
on entre los angeles et las vegas j'ai
fait un road trip extraordinaire et
voilà très bel été bah merci mais ça me
fait plaisir de 6,2 par ailleurs on a
des manques mais cela dit j'ai vu que
vous cet été c'était juste n'importe
quoi a lâché prise alors de roue libre
vestimentaire et holistique en roue
libre away complète nickel ci s'est
passé à cyril je sais pas si je t'ai
libre
c'est vrai c'est ça ouais ouais ouais
mon dégoût passé autant ses chemises ou
les allées gagner 20 tatouage c'est pas
mal j'ai quand même pris une photo avant
de sortir dans la salle de montage à
base de serviettes et où sont les vous
aviez shannon walsh kouassi jean
tatouage mais c'est un tatouage éphémère
comme dans l'émission
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces chemises l'avant vous allez voir
c'est tout merci vous avez un truc à me
dire ce qu'on m'a dit il ya quelqu'un
qui a une vidéo a lancé oui moi et sur
bas résilles édition demain
j'ai une jeune femme j'ai une jeune
femme qui est fine chronicles qui
aimerait cependant c'est pas ça c'est
pas ça vous dit si on me dit non c'est
pas ça
merci benhaim en tout cas c'est théo
leuthard baila une afrique et en plus
vous le dis ça nous fait extrêmement
plaisir que ce soit parce que tu as des
retards entre et de co2 ce matin c'est
évident c'est de venir après dans
l'émission franchement ces champs mais
on essaye rodéo ça fait des années que
travailler que moi les stagiaires il
connaît la télé comme personne je vous
jure c'est un spécialiste de télévision
tu as 22 ans et ça exactement et a déjà
une moustache de bar mitsva ouais ça
fait vingt deux ans il a travaillé on
était célibataire
je sais que cette réunion on dirait le
petit frère de ryan gosling
ouais on dirait vraiment c'est vrai on
est le petit frère de ryan gosling vous
c'est pas grave c'est ses mac drive away
non mais franchement et vous avez une
meuf non j'ai pas de bug du coup
célibataire pour un ménage suis bien
entourée entre daniel et isabelle j'ai
dansé qu'ils avaient alors c'était
génial très bon dans ses rets on a un
peu la télé dans ses allées vertes et où
merci d'atlanta barça il a été
exceptionnel aux pilotes
voilà merci et vous calmez vous était ou
non mais je le dis tout de suite je me
suis là nous pas jaloux je protège mon
ac c'est mon ami e
non c'est pas votre délire tenant pas dû
vous mr comme ça c'est fait oscar pour
votre délire autour de la table j'aime
bien delphine alors papa
[Applaudissements]
de grands panneaux et sinon j'aime
beaucoup géraldine aussi bas en
catégorie j'aime beaucoup j'ai ramé mais
ces deux catégories de cette catégorie
savez la voiture de sport elle quatre
moteurs
[Applaudissements]
un peu plus merci en tout cas merci et
kelly est avec nous ça va alors cet été
à la crise et elle est partie rare mais
ne veut pas à côté moi mettez vous
lacombe ou à ses proches ou et vous êtes
venu tout seul pour eux n'est pas venu
avec jeanine avez vous n'êtes pas
mercedes de mercedes relative c'est pour
boucher la gueulante
on n'est pas content tu sais pour voler
dans les plumes à la gente masculine on
vous a vu qu'elle a coupé ses cheveux
en fait elle a juste enlever ces faux
cheveux bonjour du seul fera ça ça sera
fabien barthez
[Applaudissements]